how's it go breasts - it did a bit of a
bit
skipper there be a bit a bit bad but I'm
a bit a bit better but I'm 6 today but
I'm making a video anyways cuz the video
has to keep coming
they can't stop so I tweeted out to you
brush while playing this goofy oh my god
to feed the sullen Queen all my god what
the [ __ ] how long have these guys been
playing feed the salad Queen
look there's a pro feed me feed me feed
me
I am the salad Queen I told you to face
she following me
follow me salad peasant is it fitted yes
bless you salad for foods inside me my
fans just go inside me this is so funny
no why oh can we uh why do you shiny son
of a [ __ ] god dammit salad Queen uh
sorry said feed foods hashtag feed
fruits all the service is becoming so
laggy now oh my god pres you're
destroying this game
I love boots thank you
the salad Queen is proud oh my god
Chinese people for [ __ ] sake till the
[ __ ] out the pros will take over China
pity pie suck what the [ __ ] thank you
oh god [ __ ] sake we have a salad come on
salad help me on dish thank you let's be
with you and ish haha oh god [ __ ] it's
so laggy I can't [ __ ] play on these
servers the salad Queen shall rule these
lands oh my god
I [ __ ] lucked out go go go go go go go
hopefully [ __ ] damn that was pretty good
can use not and you snot you finish
[ __ ] [ __ ] off bro Army's third I
think bro army should feed the solid
Queen already I love you Pitts no love
you babe
suck me off suck me up sucking me up
mate come on solid Queen
solid [ __ ] come here feed the Queen
treason no don't get sucked up now bro
army you better not to feed your queen
bro army what are you going bro army
you're doing the wrong man bro army I'm
number nine yeah good old helmet haha
why is no one feeding their salad Queen
this is so disappointing thank you let's
be with you
[ __ ] off France you can't eat this come
on let me eat you all I'm right [ __ ]
there
[ __ ] off France you're such a [ __ ]
little [ __ ] [ __ ] you France the [ __ ]
fake ass salad Queen but that [ __ ] are
you doing that can only be one salad
Queen
the liquid is number one all hail the
shallot queen picture ruler on this man
this is so much fun for us thank you for
making salad Queen the ruler of this
Lance may be like me doing this video
and I solve it stay awesome Belgium
Belgium gotta destroy [ __ ] you Belgium
and if there's any belgium bros please
enjoy being inside my belly [ __ ]